we're trying to make the exact same
mistakes as we made and Afghanistan in
the 80s
those little girls those little boys
that go to school with my daughter
they're gonna be going and they're gonna
be fighting there again we can do
something different about it flip-flops
Donald Lee in Matthew Griffin aka Lee
and Griff served multiple tours in
Afghanistan as members of the elite
Army's Special Operations force the 75th
Ranger Regiment they used to trek
through rugged mountains hunting
al-qaeda and Taliban fighters who
thought they could hide there during the
punishing Afghan winters they faced a
common paradox of modern warfare winning
hearts and minds while conducting raids
armed to the teeth when you're going
into these places it's stressful and
after you have these big barrel-chested
freedom fighters coming into this remote
mountain villages now that they've left
active duty they believe there's a
better path to peace selling flip-flops
I think people tend to forget that we're
not there to fight Afghans we were there
to remove a foreign guest from their
territory how did you get started with
combat flip-flops I had the opportunity
to go back with a medical organization
when I was there I was watching
businesses just crush it
businesses were providing opportunity
businesses were starting to take over
every street I would interact with his
business owners and they would saying no
no no you're fine we love visitors we
just don't like invaders so Lee and
Griff joined forces once again with a
new mission combat flip-flops a company
that flips the battle on how wars are
won through their business not bullets
mantra I was fortunate enough to go
visit an Afghan boot factory and I
witnessed you know that the best of
America has to offer industry this
beautiful clean boot factory and you
employing three hundred people who were
employing five and 15 family members
each a huge social impact after asking
the factory manager you know what's
gonna happen all these people when the
war ends and his response to me was oh
yeah all these people are gonna go out
of work immediately that didn't sit
right with me and I literally like
turned to my half left and there on this
table was a combat boots sole with
flip-flops long punched through so I
picked it up and it was just so
Michie it was kind of ugly and cool all
at the same time the thought occurred he
was like yeah
Americans will buy this all day so our
plan
wasn't me first started with hey let's
make some commercial production here so
that way they can stop manufacturing
parts for war in Sardinia and parts for
peace give them the opportunity that
they would otherwise not have unless it
was by some radical group okay go plant
a bomb for 50 bucks but converting a
military financed boot factory to
commercial flip-flop production proved
difficult in Afghanistan due to the lack
of other infrastructure it was a lesson
they learned the hard way there's
painful yeah we landed on the ground and
found them to be 100 percent defective
so we opted to give away all 2000 pair
to people in need in Afghanistan found
another factory in for the 4000 more
pair of flip-flops down on a personal
credit card and we got our call as
they're closing the doors on the raw
materials in the container to say hey we
just lost our boot contract it was at
that point we were just like you know it
shipped the materials here we're gonna
build them here
family affair ends 5:00 a.m. to midnight
for months putting thousands of pairs of
footballs together still armed with
their objective of employing people in
conflict zones they weren't satisfied
slinging thongs out of grips garage so
they turned their attention to a
different kind of war producing a
similar kind of situation Colombia when
we looked at it I'm just kind of dicey
it kind of fits our model Afghanistan
and Colombia are very similar and the
fact that they're mountain people living
in developing nation we were recovering
from a narco finance counterinsurgency
war we've been waging the war on drugs
in Colombia you know finally we got
around to realizing that hey you know no
way can we you'll fight this when a
military front but we can also fight
this on an economic front have more
positive sustainable change people do
what they have to do to feed their
families so it's common sense right what
happens when there's no jobs crime goes
up right you give them jobs
you give my honest wage time goes down
boys did you guys say what free markets
and free minds like yeah that's how you
do it they pumped up production while
helping locals move from cartels to
craftsmanship but Griffin Lee still had
unfinished business in Afghanistan so
they hatched a plan to go back and make
silk Shamas in a female owned factory
they partnered with Hasina share John
who had previously started clandestine
schools for girls under the Taliban to
go up and actually do this while the
Taliban wasn't
or to smuggle books and teachers in and
create these underground schools that
you know that woman's got it together
right she's pretty cool yeah in
partnership with share John's charity
aid Afghanistan for education each
product combat flip-flops makes in her
Kabul based factory now funds between a
day to a month of school for women the
women they're there the constant they
have been the widows and they've been
fighting there for 30 years there's like
15 percent of the women in Afghanistan
are literate and they're raising the
young males and then you have an
illiterate mom chances are you're gonna
have an illiterate kid and so if you
want to change how these radicals are
getting recruited if you want to take
their recruitment base away from them
you'll educate women all of them that's
what we're aiming to do with that from
sales just in 2015 they say they have
provided over 21 years of school to
Afghan girls building on this model
combat flip-flops ties new products to a
social good like Tom's but accessible to
non hipsters how much do you put towards
those projects while keeping a viable
business you tell somebody or gonna give
away 10 to 20% of your profits they're
gonna they're gonna look at your side
ways but it's a sustainable model for us
because we lunch we run so lean and we
use technology to our advantage the
company is on track to triple its sales
this year despite getting flop blocked
by Uncle Sam I have stuff held up in
customs right now on a customs hold for
a product that's gonna put little Afghan
girls in school I got to pay a 14% duty
tariff on it three time Afghan vet run
in a small business we've been fighting
there for 14 years I lost six brothers
there and we can't push the policy
through to promote businesses between
the two countries
it's sad but they don't plan to stop
anytime soon and Laos they hired artisan
families to turn scrap from unexploded
landmines into jewelry which funds
further demining of the area you just
end up assembling your own flip-flops in
your garage and then you kind of explode
back out you have products and Laos and
Colombia and elsewhere how do you find
those communities the job that was
performed in the military if you needed
to get got to do a bit of ditching we
did that hunting down people for years
so it's a very easy transition and a
very actually fun transition to be able
to go do that in a positive manner in a
business the u.s. dropped 250 to 280
million landmines over Laos and 60s to
deny the Viet Cong access to the ho Chi
Minh
trail ready ready now I think it's the
equivalent of a b-52 load every eight
minutes for nine years you know we've
seen the effects of that we used to drop
those bombs we know what it does we know
the damage that it causes firsthand and
stuffs been laying around there for 40
years now there's nearly 50 million of
them on the ground and over half the
victims are kids
we've been doing the same thing since
what Vietnam and joy doesn't seem to be
working
combat flip-flops is partnered with mag
America to clear 1200 square meters of
landmines this year all from sales of
their bomb bling but Griffin Lee won't
rest until they've brought their way of
nation-building to One More war ravaged
country in the same way that we leave a
vacuum when we and all the defense
contracts elsewhere same thing here
faucets cut off we're seeing small
American businesses suffer because of
what's going on so we said hey well what
commercially we'll make a product and an
American defense manufacturer from
another veteran owned business and we'll
start selling briefcases and bags we
have the most talented team oriented
people in the world coming back and
working their way into our society and
we deserve to give them every
opportunity I think what drives us is
just being able to help people no matter
what happened over there no matter what
I saw over there I always go back to
this one memory and I was sick and I got
off that helicopter and I had 102 fever
we were above 10,000 feet and we're just
snow on the ground I think it was like
5:00 in the morning 4:00 in the morning
local during Ramadan and I'm standing
outside watching this road just freezing
sick you know ready to pass out and this
Afghan woman sends her two daughters out
freezing snow here's a cup of warm goat
milk chai a warm pita bread with some
marmalade like dude if you want
marmalade it's gonna take you three days
to go get it and this woman didn't know
me you know I'm standing I'm standing
with a rifle in her backyard watching
this road made me really there's people
here that that are happy that we're here
we're trying to help but you gotta go
back to what I said about being an
invader being a visitor right you're one
of the other she treated me as a visitor
and took care of me my drives are a
little bit different over the past few
years I came to realize that I was the
same age in 1989 as my daughter is now
and we're preparing to make the exact
same mistakes as we made in Afghanistan
in the 80s and if we make those mistakes
those little girls those little boys go
to school with my daughter they're gonna
be going and they're gonna be fighting
there again and ten years we've
witnessed this happen in Iraq we witness
that happen in the 80s we can do
something different about it we can make
a change it's not a cliche we owe it to
our kids and not having to go fight for
our mistakes I don't want them to pay
for our sins